foreign
I am 22 years old
I'm from Kurdistan
I came on vacation to Tehran for two
days with my brother
I got arrested for not wearing my veil
properly
then I was beaten repeatedly and
eventually went into a coma and died
I'm Nika I'm 16 years old
I dressed all in black took my water
bottle
and a small towel to protect myself from
tear gas
I went on this street to protest
I got kidnapped tortured
I'm Nico's shattered skull
I am her battered body
delivered to her family 10 days after
she got kidnapped
eventually she was buried without
warning in some Far Away Cemetery
I went to protest with my mother
she said don't let go of my hand
but I did
and I got shot
I died in front of her eyes
I'm Kian
I'm only 10 years old
I wanted to become a scientist
but my body was riddled with bullets
I am the boat on Wheels he made with his
little hands
carrying 70 more children Over the
Rainbow
killed in a similar way
I am kian's father who was shot and
paralyzed for life
the karate boy
I am the son of a peddler brought up in
poverty
I was hanged at dawn during the morning
prayers
I am one of the last sentences of
Muhammad to his father
don't tell Mom they want to execute me
I am too much a rapper tortured and kept
in solitary confinement for months and
months
I am
nilu fare we are journalists who
reported on the death of Masa
we have been in prison since
I am 537 victims of this revolution in
Iran
the ones who got executed the ones who
got tortured the tens of thousands of
wounded and arrested and imprisoned
innocent men and women
I am the raised fist of young girls with
their hair flowing in the Wind
I am their glorious Dance I'm their
blood their size their tears
their dreams their eyes
their lost Eyes by rubber bullets
I am the reason they stood up
I am freedom
and
I'm also got shifter
I'm an artist
I'm living a life of exile for the past
15 years
I was forced to leave my motherland
but I kept fighting as a woman
for life
to be free
my choices and existence as an exiled
female artist was my battle
exist to resist
but the courageous Fearless Generation Z
who started this revolution they didn't
leave they stayed and they went on the
street and died for a woman life and
freedom
death breaks the cage
but doesn't kill the bird as Rumi says
we carry these birds in us let them fly
on their way to Victory
Wars discrimination
dictatorships racism it is all the same
Iran is the rest of the world the world
is Iran
woman life Freedom black lives matter
glory to Ukraine
ignorance and fear is the cause of it
all
we can all decide today to be the bridge
to unite rather than separate
any child living in a dictatorship any
Refugee child being denied help any
child being killed in war
if we ignore one we ignore our own
children
and we deny Humanity
the poet said he once said
human beings are members of a whole
in creation of one Essence and soul
if one member is Afflicted with pain
other members uneasy will remain
if you have no sympathy for human pain
the name of human
you cannot retain
thank you